hey 42 here NASA estimates that the
value of all the minerals in the
asteroid belt exceeds this ought to put
it in other words roughly a hundred
billion dollars for each person alive
welcome to the finger prints of koala
bears are virtually indistinguishable
from those of humans in 1959 United
States Postal Service attempted to
deliver mail by cruise missile and
successfully shipped cargo from New
Jersey to Florida in 22 minutes the
yin-yang symbol was first used in
ancient Rome not China
your heart rate rises as much as 30
percent during a yawn the first word
ever spoken on the moon was okay an
apple will wake you up better in the
morning than coffee this is because of
an apples high sugar content if you keep
a goldfish in the dark it will
eventually turn white in nearly every
species of mammal the female lives
longer than the male there is a service
in Boulder Colorado called hangover
helpers that will come to your place the
morning after a party drink Gatorade
cook everyone a breakfast burrito and
cleanup for around $20 per person Pope
Francis the leader of the Catholic
Church once worked as a bouncer in an
Argentinean bar John F Kennedy had his
press secretary purchased 1,200 Cuban
cigars and confirmed that the purchase
was complete before signing the
documents that made the embargo against
Cuba official Beatles tastes like apples
wasps taste like pine nuts and worms
like fried bacon in Australia Jedi is an
official religion known as Jediism it
has over 70,000 followers the word dude
was first used in the late 1800s as an
insult towards men who were overly
concerned with keeping up of the latest
fashions in ten minutes a hurricane
releases more energy than all the
world's and nuclear weapons combined
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you